i must say that communications with
chernobyl
have been a bit shaky there have been
interruptions and restorations depending
on different times of the day an agreed
framework
is required is needed something specific
is needed if we are to reinforce the
safety of the installations in the in in
the country so i will not get lost into
um
you know
seeking a
fixed format um
which would be the only uh alternative
and the way forward so we are still
discussing this um
and and i you know i'm
aiming at having something relatively
soon relatively soon
what we have is
actually a degrading situation
which
is
a concerning
the situation for us because gradually
we are
losing it doesn't mean that we are
losing everything but we are losing a
significant amount of information
green is green and red is
no information and you can see that
this is in safeguards terms
it's not a good situation because we are
losing
information safeguards is predicated on
the basis of a
constant
monitoring capacity that we can have
well i don't have
any investigative
capacity to
understand what
what what is the real reason uh behind a
particular interruption at a particular
place on a particular time of the day
it's impossible for me
the only thing we are doing is of course
we are dealing with this whenever this
happens we try to establish or
re-establish contact as soon as possible
in some cases we were able to redress
situations in some other cases this has
proven to be so far
not not possible
ukraine and the russian federation want
to work with us with us they agree to
work with us and they are prepared to
work with us perhaps the gravity of my
tone has to do with the gravity of the
situation
because it's a very dire situation
and we need to move fast and i'm
i am aware of the responsibility we have
and the expectations that there are